[Music]
all right i'm going to play my sub
heroic sharkboy
so this is my mod oh and cole 385 gifted
holy smokes my mind is blown right now
okay let's go c5
so we're gonna play like a sicilian
structure against one one b3
and now um oh my god
josie miku with the 64 party raid let's
develop our knight
and let's control more of the center
with d5
okay so this is a reverse nimzo
indian and how should we deal with this
pin
how should we deal with the spin thank
you guys so much appreciate it
amazing so queen c7 but remember the
rule
when you can use a lesser value piece
rather than a queen that is generally a
good idea so
what is the simplest not every one of
your pieces needs to be distributing the
kovan vaccine
bishop d7 is the simplest now
we need to get this bishop out we have
two ways of doing that the move g6 i'll
show this after the game
is a little bit dubious on account of
bishop takes f6
uh and that kind of ruins our pawn
structure in a way that i don't want so
let us play e6
and eventually no we're gonna play a6
but there's no russian playing a6 now
let's go bishop out to d6 that is the
more active square you see that he took
on his own volition now we don't want to
let
well we actually really do so let's hm
so this is a really interesting position
knight be free gifting to jesse miku
how can we ensure that this knight
leaves e5 and this is a move that i need
to spell out after the game
because explaining it now would take me
a little bit too long but we're going to
play the move
knight out to d7 we are basically going
to try to force a trade
now i know a lot of you are thinking
wait a second this blunders the pawn
what are you doing
what are you doing okay but give it a
chance because if he takes that pawn he
opens up the g
file and that basically gives us massive
attacking opportunities so
this is better than queen c7 because
there white can play f4 and cement the
knight
he plays f4 anyway but guess what now
we can simply take the knight anyway and
then our queen could potentially access
the g5 square
which has been opened up as a
consequence of him
taking with the f1 we always need to ask
ourselves that question when the
position has transformed substantively
as i've argued time and time again we
ask ourselves okay how has the position
transformed at go watches to your
wondering thank you
what should we do now that was a bit of
a blunder
that was a bit of a blunder look around
the whole position take on e3
and now um should we take on d4
yes or no should we take on d4 what do
you guys think
so here holy smokes
edca watches oh my god 25
who is this man we got more hype
we should because we destroy his pawn
chain
again after the game i will guide you
through the exact logic but
wait a minute wait a minute we got 25
from ecco watches who is this guy he's
on fire
oh my god guys i can't believe this
it just happens every day now and i'm
you will bring me to tears eventually
this is unbelievable okay but we got a
game to win and i think that's what he
wants from us
so let's castle we gotta complete our
develop we gotta complete our
development
okay let's not forget about that now can
you guys propose a way to simply improve
the position what is a
sort of a typical classic move in such a
position
to improve the position well it's too
early for f6 yeah rook c8 okay to see it
now we're leaving this rook on f8
for a very specific reason later we
might want to play okay so he goes
recovery that's a good move
now this pawn we don't need to worry
about that pawn is irrelevant in a
minute
oh 17
from innovative panda this is unreal
un freaking real we're going to bring
our queen back for the defense
of the f7 pawn over protection
and now we are ready for a particular
kind of move
well we'll see this is unbelievable
thank you innovative for 17
i mean you guys are something else
absolutely something else okay let's go
b6 for now
let's go b6 and blunt blunt the bishop
okay so actually this i haven't played
this ideally i think i'm
okay so we need to change up the
position we need to give
our pieces some air how do we pump up
the air on the king side
what move i previously mentioned this
move
we rejected it previously but now it's
time for this move and that is the move
f6
and the way i would encourage you guys
to think about this is we just
kind of we get some air to breathe on
the king's side
so g6 i'll talk about after the game as
well
thanks again both of you you're freaking
beasts you're freaking
beasts okay edcawatches says i gotta go
no problem thanks man for the 25 you are
a boss
and you can shoot me an email by the way
uh though and three bucks from naino
also
so knight f6 of course we don't want to
play gf
okay what now what do we do how do we
how do we close down the e file
we're actually do we have anything oh we
have something sexy
we have something sexy guys okay oh
actually no we don't we don't
we don't knight chief i thought it was
94 is the move yeah yeah
i thought we had something cool forget
it it didn't work i'll show you guys
after the game what i thought
let me write this down but i
am starting to hallucinate
okay so we're up upon we have a past
pawn on e4
and what he's just done is he's moved
the rook away from
f1 how should we exploit that how do we
do that
what should we do in order to explain
that we should do is double the rooks
right we should double the rooks because
he's removed the rook from the f-file
which logically means and now let's go
e5 intercepting the bishop not letting
it get to us
and now we can oh no he can't because of
queen c4 winning the bishop so let's
first go
let's cover some ground here with a move
let's go queen e6 stopping queen c4
controlling the square centralizing our
queen
and then we are going to complete the
doubling of it rooks i have to give
credit here to shark he's defending very
very well
but uh you guys should be able to see
into sense
that the position is starting to slip
away from him i think
okay so here i'm not sure about this
actually let me think
so let's go rook c7 let's defend
everything and then we can swing the
rook around to f7
oh my god oxy time gifting 10 freaking
subscriptions
this is unbelievable oxy time now
getting into the party another 10 subs
you guys are crazy i'm just saying that
h6 to create the uh the little hole for
a king now we gotta go rook h7
we might get there tonight at this rate
this is unbelievable
yeah so i'm playing a little bit faster
because of the um
because of the um time constraints but
i'll i'll
spell everything out after the game so
what i'm going to try to do here is just
talk the king away tuck the king away
and
everything is going to be easier with
the king tucked away now we're going to
intercept the queen's control over f1
and we're going to tempt him into taking
on a7 which may be good
um okay king h2 is really really good
man shark is playing incredibly well
here as well my opponents today gotta
give them credit rook f6
i'm trying to get the rook over to g6 in
order to contest
that other rook okay now oh my god man
rubbish banana
subs flying in holy smokes ravaged
banana min
you're you're crazy man five and five
oh my lands girls and boys this is crazy
absolutely freaking insane
and i might lose this game that let me
focus here for a second
this is amazing guys 66.71
okay let's go e3 let's open up the
position
now let's go bishop e4
yeah shark is playing this ridiculously
well thank you so much min
thank you ravage banana this guy
is a beast that is why he's my mod
and that is why he's my friend he's good
as hell
okay let me go here this is actually a
draw now
but i'm gonna try to win this
oh my god cash flow real he's throwing
them in
the subs are coming in
oh god this is bad
this is very bad ladies and gentlemen
i'm going to lose this
you
draw good job shark
amazing game amazing game by
shark no come on but but you played
really well don't don't be down on
yourself for not winning that that was
incredible
that was incredible uh that was a great
fight cash flow real thanks for the 10
gifted
that's my first draw actually um
that is my freaking first draw amazing
okay so
lots happened here lots happened here i
think i was better for most of the game
but um but that was uh incredibly played
so
okay so we can check uh
yeah lost only three rating points for
that
b3 can't lose that's right
look at the accuracy okay this is this
is okay guys look at this
freaking look at this this is called
this is called effort
from both of us
you believe that
well well well
well well well
okay that's that's some uh that's some
effort yeah
back and forth we went so basically like
there's so much to unpack here i'm
excited about this
now let's unpack this for a second so
basically
um
basically basically this one was good
okay this man is gonna be a gm one day
so okay so this is normal bishop d7
okay bishop d7 yeah i actually have
before essentially
essentially ensuring that bishop c6 is
not gonna double our pawns
okay e6 now
g6 is also possible but then bishop
takes f6
yeah that forces us to take this way and
now white strikes in the center with c4
so you know this is um this is very
undesirable
so e6 d3 bishop d6
shark takes it and goes 95. okay now
queen c7 is kind of the typical move
but the problem here is he goes f4
thanks again guys for
uh for the subs incredible almost 6700 i
can't believe it
okay anyways i'm really hyped right now
so f4
defends the knight and what i want you
guys to see
is that uh it's very hard now to
dislodge this knight so knight d7
basically forces the knight out of e5
now if knight takes c6 and bishop takes
g7 right this is
i think what would make a lot of people
hesitate i ruled this out intuitively
like my
understanding here was that okay go rook
g8 and look at the pieces
aimed at the king side what move would
combine this
and create an attack like can you guys
give me an example of a good move here
which and to be fair i don't think that
maybe black has full compensation
objectively
but something like queen h4 or queen g5
all of these are good yep
so queen g5 for example inducing g3 and
black can always cast along
yes castling long contains its own risks
but
this is all about buying yourself time
buying yourself time
uh in order to continue the attack this
gets very very messy
this is a typical narrative bs sacrifice
but you guys get the rationale now
so f4 okay so takes takes queen g5 and
here shark
makes a mistake d4 is i think the only
mistake of the game
and and and this of course allows me to
take on e3
which is kind of undesirable
and instead i think that the move
probably queen f3 was to be preferred
attacking f7
and only after castling something like
d4 i think the position is about equal
here
although black maybe goes f6 and because
white is not developed
i think black has the initiative that's
how i would phrase it
but after d4 queen e3 the reason i took
on d4 is because this
if you guys think about it is a pawn
chain what i just highlighted is a pawn
chain
how do you deal with plunging you try to
undermine the bass and here i literally
have a chance to
immediately destroy the pawn train so i
figured okay this creates another
weakness on e5
and this weakness is gonna be hard to
defend so queen e2 castles
knight c3 and here i actually think i
made perhaps a mistake i'm not sure
where exactly
i went wrong but it was somewhere around
this plane that sharks started playing
incredibly well rook f3 is a really good
move
rook f3 is a really good move because
this sends the rook to g3 and it
prepares the double rocks all of a
sudden i realize my king could end up
being in some trouble
if the rook is lifted to g3 how would we
refer to the bishop on d4 what does it
have
a lot of time guys to use our con to use
our vocabulary
to go full circle what does it have a
lot of
potential wow potential energy exactly
and it has a lot of potential entry
because the moment this pawn is gone the
moment it's gone
the bishop is gonna be the greatest
beast in the world
it is also a bad bishop defending a good
pawn which essentially means that it has
potential energy
that is why i was discouraged from
playing f5 although this is the computer
stop move
f5 on poissant and now black has a move
that i missed
could anybody spot it what intermediate
move does black now have to kill the
potential energy of the bishop
to kill its potential energy and that is
the move e5 not being afraid of anything
like this
because if rook takes f3 and e takes d4
so
this would have been i think my biggest
chance at a big advantage but i dropped
the queen back
now doubling rooks b6 and rook h3 just
continuing the attack f6 is correct
and now rookie three now the sexy move
that i thought that i have
is knight to g4 the line that i
calculated was the following rook takes
up
okay so if queen takes g4 then it's
checkmate
so rook takes f8 happens and again if
queen takes g4 then this is checkmate
but
white has this move what do you guys
think that i hallucinated when
calculating this line what idea
quick select another sub with prime
thank you sir
yeah and i thought oh rook f1 bishop g1
knight f2 checkmate
it is check daniel so this doesn't work
that is why we have to cover up the e
file with knight e4 so take stakes
okay now the bishop covers the pawn and
my bishop now has a lot of potential
energy so we have a reverse of fortune
reversal of fortune regards to the
bishop now my bishop has a lot of
potential energy the moment the rook
moves away from e3
i have to consider the move e3 opening
up the diagonal
okay i hope i'm making sense in the way
that i'm looking at this position so
rookie one
doubling rooks e5 to kill white's bishop
queen a6 is really strong and what shark
did really well here is he continues to
find counterplay in every type of
position rook d1
getting the open file h3 and now very
patient h3
a4 improving the position a5
wouldn't f8 have defended a7 um
in which position oh you mean here
well the problem is uh no because this
is not made
you have to understand that there's
bishop g1 that is the issue right bishop
g1
is a very nasty move and now white is
threatening checkmate
that's why i saw the need to defend a7
h6 to stop rook d to take the sting out
of it
and okay so here rook five to f6 i'm
trying to go to g6 to eliminate the rook
but rook d8 comes
i decide to exploit the weakening of the
first rank but queen c8 is super strong
because this force is a queen trade and
a queen trade is good for white why
because now white's bishop is a lot
stronger than my bishop my bishop
is still staring at the pawn white
bishop is multitasking it's being a
beast
and it's blockading my own bishop so an
end game leads to a clear disparity in
white's
pieces being more active than mine and
even though i'm technically still up
upon
look at how weak all of these pawns are
and shark just mows them down
bishop c5 i'm not sure about this lets
me open up my bishop
but still he continues to mow down the
pawns takes takes
in this position black is the one
fighting for equality now i was able to
maintain equality
this is just a draw and ultimately we
ran into a time scramble
so i'll skip the rest of the game here
but really an incredibly played middle
game by shark i think i played quite
well as well
but but such a rich game so many things
happen here so many concepts that we can
that we can observe here so after h6
couldn't he have played bishop takes h6
well remember there is a queen here
the queen actually defends the pawn and
what devronicus is saying okay pawn
takes is not possible
because of the pin but there is a queen
on e6 guarding that square
okay is that clear the analysis said he
made a blunder well i think the blunder
white's only mistake i think was giving
the pawn i'm not sure where i went wrong
i think most of my moves were very
sensible
um i think somewhere here maybe i
i didn't find the most decisive way to
act uh and i think well as i indicated
before f5 on move 17 i think was the
cleanest path to a big advantage because
yeah because if white doesn't take on
passant then i get air to breathe for my
pieces i can go rook f7 i don't have to
worry about my king
i can sort of relocate my focus on other
sides of the board
um and what i missed was this movie five
right missing these tactics
oftentimes what decides the game at this
very high level
if that makes sense let's play push to
pawn let's go
we are black again so that's fine with
me
oh the uh things are misaligned one sec
i don't know why it's so misaligned but
let's play an opening called the chagorn
yeah i'm not sure why it's so misaligned
guys i don't know what happened
this is really annoying
yeah not sure what happened here
sorry guys one sec please yeah why don't
we just ignore this for now
um so he plays a london system
well by the time i correct this i'm
actually going to lose on time which is
kind of ironic
i'm not sure where my time is
okay there we go
okay so let's take it
let's take it no no i wanted you guys to
see the time
so this is the london system and uh we
will just develop our pieces here
there is nothing really to write home
about just developing our pieces
now what would be a good way to develop
this bishop who can propose for me a
nice little
like what are the two possibilities here
for developing this bishop
obviously the first one is e6 but let's
fianchetto the reason i want to
fianchetto and i don't want to close off
the diagonal for this bishop
and there is a very specific reason why
i didn't want to develop the light
squared bishop first
there is a very specific reason why i
didn't want to develop the light squared
bishop first which i will explain after
the game
it related to weakening this b7 pawn so
we solved the problem by first fiance we
can even pre-move castling here
we're basically gonna castle against
anything other than bishop a6 and my
headphones just died
so you guys will have to not hear the
move sounds for a little bit
like freaking headphones constantly i'm
dying now here's the interesting thing
um i'm going to make a move which to a
lot of you guys
will seem very bad and it will seem very
bad because it ruins the kingside bond
structure what move am i thinking of
who wants to tell me the move that may
seem to
ruin the king side pawn structure well
it's not h5 it's actually bishop f5
and you guys might be looking at this
and saying what girl what are you doing
you're opening up the king side but
here's the thing there's a couple
extenuating circumstances if he takes on
f5 and let's hope he does
i get very good control of the center
particularly the e4 square number one
number two
because i fianchettoed my bishop and i
have a knight on f6 and my queen is
nearby i have a lot of beef
on the king's side and white doesn't
really have attacking prospects it's
hard for white to get
a lot of pieces into the king's side
quickly i'll show this after the game
but uh this is a very typical move in
these positions i'm sure even this
position exactly has occurred before
so you shouldn't be afraid necessarily
to play a move like this
um and and you want to tie this into the
concrete circumstances on the board
the higher rated we get the more
concrete our considerations have to
become okay
yeah people say i sound better with the
headphones off
okay so he attacks the pawn now
there is a very interesting subtlety
here if we go queen to d7
first of all if we go b6 actually let's
just go b6 i don't see why not
i was a little bit concerned about uh
removing the defender on my knight
but we can always defend it with rook c8
so i really don't see the problem in
this
and now we can position our knight on e4
we can also beef up
the pawns by going e6 and and sort of
securing
everything here a little bit further
knight a5 is also possible although i
don't want to keep that knight on the
rim
but in the future we can absolutely play
knight a5 let's see what he does
it really depends on how white decides
to play this
okay so knight bd2 let's first of all go
e6 let's
secure these pawns we don't have to rush
with the move knight e4 that's not
really going anywhere
yeah we that's actually one of the key
long-term plans of going king h8 rook g8
and repurposing this seeming deficiency
on the king side actually in our favor
you'll find that this commonly happens
right it seems like this
benefits white but the reality is this
open file what we call a semi-open file
because
there's only a pawn of one color on the
file and it happens to be a white pawn
which benefits black here because we are
the ones who can get the rook to g8
and begin attacking operations thank you
tricking nine for the prime
getting us closer to that 30 freaking
6700 i
have trouble even saying that number
freaking ridiculous
thank you sir candidate master is
correct so he's burning a lot of clock
here 95. now how do we deal with
this situation do we take on e5 what do
you guys think if not what do we do
if yes why
so the problem with the move like knight
back to e7 is that it leaves white
tonight on an outpost and we don't want
the knight on an outpost
not every one of your thought processes
has to be
incredibly complex some sort of rocket
science
knight on e5 is active we're taking it
now where is this knight going
where is this knight going there's
several schools of thought about how to
yeah
beautiful little outpost now if he takes
it we play f e
and we get this like wedge in the center
i don't know how else to define it
we get this really nice you know massive
pawns in the center we can then play
f6 and remove his last pawn from the
center he goes knight f3 for that reason
now what plan can we now fall back on
i've described this plan before
this plan was proposed what can we start
to do now that we've sort of established
everything in the center
this pawn is actually helping us because
it's drying things up
and it's it's making it very hard for
white to actually get anything done
so kha now actually i made an inaccuracy
i should have made a prophylactic move
let's see if my opponent exploits it
well
let's see if my opponent is able to
exploit it but i actually think i should
have
played the move rook to c8 stopping
c4 i think white should play c4 here and
actually try to open the position up
to distract my attention from the king
side
not an easy move to play though i mean
this takes some serious understanding
and he's burning way too much clock
right now
although even then we will just take the
pawn and proceed with our plan with rook
g8 i don't really mind the d
file getting opened i'm going to take on
c4 i'm
guys this guy is honorable most people
who watch my stream are honorable
i'm not going to assume that people are
stream sniping okay
that goes against my philosophies
even if he is big deal all right now he
prepares
c4 so he has the right idea but i think
the execution is a little bit too slow
what should we do how do we stop c4 and
i just mentioned this move those of you
who are attentive
should should uh have no trouble with
this move rookie now queen c7 right
guys again remember the rule the queen
we are going to leave
for the king side we need to use the
least valuable piece for this kind of
stuff
now what do we do how do we continue our
plan
so we need to be very attuned to
the opportunities that have presented
themselves as a result of his last move
we don't just put our head down and say
rugged rook g8
we need to be very careful okay what is
now possible he's like wait a minute the
knight has left the king side
that means there are certain squares
such as h4 which are now available to
our pieces
queen h4 is so much stronger than rook
g8 because it brings a piece in with
tempo
that's a golden opportunity and then
when we do play rook g8
there might be hell to pay here for
white so right let's go rook g8
he's probably going to go f3 and then
we're going to start looking for tactics
and there's a couple of beautiful ideas
there
okay let me calculate something if you
guys don't mind give me a second please
hmm yeah there's an idea that doesn't
quite work okay
but um yeah so so i was thinking about
sacking uh with bishop h6 and basically
just throwing everything at him
but i'm going to make crazy argument
guys there's no need for that
there is no need for that where can the
knight sink its teeth into
where it literally the only way i
describe it sink its teeth into g3
okay now we want to open up the g-file
we do that by repositioning the bishop
to h6 now we start looking for tactics
that relate to the g-file
white is completely busted here and now
ladies and gentlemen we what is a very
simple way of nurturing the advantage
how do we increase the pressure down the
g funnel simple
simple chess bishop f4 is a great move
but i want yeah double the works let's
bring all the beef in
bring in the beef hashtag bring the beef
double them baby girl
double them baby now we have ideas like
queen takes h3 which we have to consider
now we can bring the bishop into
addition page form
methodical prepare slowly attack fast
that's the key prepare slowly attack
fast
now we look for tactics and do we find
them
let me think guys for a second
i want to find a nice way to win the
game in style
i am failing to do so
hmm let me think
yeah we're gonna go 92 and queen h3 that
is the simplest i was trying to find
some sort of fancy line
but um this is simple enough and we're
completely winning because this is now
coming in
the game is over so nice game
and a simple simple attacking game no
crazy stuff
but we don't need crazy stuff oftentimes
in order to win
the game and that was the case here
so against the london i really like the
move c5 i highly recommend it to people
e3 takes takes now this leads to an
interesting pawn and balance right
uh i have traded my c pawn and i do need
to be for white's epon
which is kind of an interesting scenario
right
black has a more more pawns in this in
the center
but white has this pawn majority on the
queen side i don't think this favors
anyone in particular
this just leads to an interesting
structure so now
i develop my pieces now g6 so why did i
not develop my bishop to g4 dr olano
gifting to smucker y shaft thank you sir
well the reason is that this leaves the
pawn on b7 vaster lee with a prime
i drink zero this is not soda this is
sparkling water
the queen b3 here is super nasty it
attacks the pawn on b7
it's actually not that easy to defend it
part of the reason it's not easy to
defend it
is because the bishop on f4 controls b8
so the move rook b8
is not possible here and the move b6
allows bishop b5 now it's actually a
very bad thing
that the knight has lost its protector
okay
queen b6 there's takes takes this ruins
the pawn structure
i don't love these positions because why
does the idea of going 95
this layers on some unpleasant pressure
so
for that reason you want to go g6 yeah
queen see it is possible but it's a
little bit awkward is what i'm trying to
say
what i'm trying to say guys is that this
is a little bit awkward in 95
much like in my first speedrun game can
lead to some unpleasant consequences you
remember the job game
right you kind of remember just to
compare you remember this game right i
played 95 much the same ideas
bishop b5 becomes possible now if we
compare this
to this position now i'm on the
receiving end of something like this
takes takes bishop b5 comes in i want
you guys just to see
that white is an initiative right that's
all i'm trying to argue so g6
skirts the problem by keeping the bishop
on c8 rendering queen b3
uh rendering queen b3 useless right
rendering queen b3 useless okay
so h3 uh stopping
bishop g4 now we develop now the main
reason
we won the game is this new bishop f5
and i want people
to really understand this move did this
move make sense to you guys and
let me just recap
um visually speaking
okay bob meister says bishop f5 makes
zero sense to me
bob meister you're gonna be my litmus
test i wanted to make 100
sense to you okay great now
let's trace what you guys are thinking
what i feel like is going through your
brain about meister and correct me if
i'm wrong
you're looking at this move and you're
saying girl right look at look at these
pawns
why are you making this so ugly this is
doubled the king is open
what are you getting in return for that
i'm like well come on
like damn girl well here's the thing
what you need to look past the visual
deficiencies
of the pawn structure and you need to
look at and specifically notice a couple
of things
first of all these pawns are combining
to increase their control over this very
important central square
on that central square could appear at
night and this is very similar to a lot
of variations right you can think about
the marotzi bind variation of the
accelerated dragon for example
same concept two pawns combining to
control a square that's just a
proven method to increase your control
over the center
that's like the same thing wearing
different clothes
but the second thing is that i think you
would agree with me the g
file gets opened right this is what's
called a semi-open file who can benefit
from the g-file well clearly black is
much closer
to putting a rook on g8 and attacking
white then white is putting a rook on
let's say g3 and attacking black
right that's just a fact of chess
because your two moves away
from getting a rook to g8 the third
thing to notice is that
even though your eyes are telling you
hey this is ugly
your brain needs to tell you there's no
problem because we can just play e6
and we did and there's literally this
pawn is as robust as
any right this center is all protecting
each other
so this is completely and perfectly
acceptable
does this begin to make more sense when
i explain it like that
uh bot meister uh
no i wouldn't say it's a mistake but i
would consider going bishop e2
or or even queen c2 trying to trade on
white's own terms
right well it's not the white's pieces
yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely we're
very happy to hear that
so b6 here defending the pawn knight bd2
e6
95 we take it and we go knight e4
guess what we're reaping the benefits
from
our uh our move bishop f5 so
very understandably white ghost knight
f3 i think white should have taken on e4
now we go rook king h8 i think rook c8
would have been better
stopping c4 and here i think the last
chance really for white is to go c4 open
up the position as quickly as possible
distract black's attention after rook d
rook d won roxy and we stopped c4
you guys might notice wait a second
can't he take nope
because this is defended and black is up
upon
and so knight t4 happens we go queen h4
exploiting the deficiency
here here gazda youtube is not lagging
behind it's just we're uploading a video
a day
doing the best we can so paul shows he
did do that
that that's literally exactly what he
did that's what that's what he did
if he did it as soon as possible he
can't do it here because the bishop is
hanging
so he does it does it here but it
weakens the g3 square that's literally
exactly
what the problem is um
and um well we take toward the center
usually now bishop h6 to open the g
file double literally everything is very
clear
he can't take the queen because of the g
file pin
drop the queen back the next move will
be bishop f4 with crushing position
why not take e5 pawn asks rockwell i
which position rockwell
here the pawn is defended by the rook so
at no point could i have taken that pawn
right
here it's defended by that hidden bishop
so the pawn
is is not takeable unfortunately
what if king white king goes to f aids
um not sure where
well if he goes to oh f1 well then you
lose control of the bishop i can just
take the bishop so
in these positions when all of your
pieces are attacking there is just no
possible way
that that there is a defense to be found
can white take the knight with the
bishop please tell
well yes so he can problem is going to
be look at these dark squares right look
at look carefully at these dark squares
if white now goes f4
what is black's crushing move who can
tell me and min i'm almost ready for you
if you're still around
what you should notice here you look at
the rook you look at the queen and say
ha
if the bishop was gone from g7 it would
be czechos how can the bishop move and
make the most damage while it's at it
boom goes the dynamite
white must defend the pawn and in the
time that white does that the bishop
takes another pawn
with the devastating threat of queen h2
white white's position collapses
completely
does that make sense so but was f3
necessary
asks henrik uh dc well i actually think
maybe white shouldn't have done
that but in my opinion if white doesn't
play f3 then my idea is to go bishop h6
and double rooks much like i did in the
game
i simply do not see a good defensive
resource against that because white is
no play on the other side of the board
that's why counter play is so important
because without counter play
you simply just you keep nothing you can
do there's too many pieces attacking
well if he plays g3 then look at this
bishop you bury the bishop alive and you
give up h3
so rook t3 i'm not sure how that helps
bishop h6 i understand what you're
trying to do
but you just and also knight d2 is a
threat forking
the queen of the rook right so what you
guys are suggesting is putting a
band-aid over it
but ultimately my pieces are so active
that once i double rooks
there will be hell to pay regardless of
how you try to rearrange
your resources you're just too passive
knight f3 queen h3
knight f3 you sever the connection
between the rook and the pawn i take on
h3
okay so you're just not going to win and
if king h1 the knight takes f2
too many things have to be taken into
account here counter play is an attack
that is mounted in response to some sort
of pressure or attack
counter attack right an attack of your
own
oh i personally don't really care the
computer gives minus two
um i don't really care uh
okay harshit i encourage you to ask a
question only once because i do
see it so c4 opens up a file
by opening up a file you are distracting
in a sense black's attention from the
attack right
you can play rook a to d1 and attack the
queen and at least white gets some
activity
right in return for defending against
the attack
all right guys um does that all i hope
that all makes sense to everybody
i hope that all makes sense to everybody
well but meister but but that's a
limited you know that's a limited
mentality
that's a limited or that's a limited
limiting belief that i wouldn't play x
i encourage people not to tell that to
themselves now i'm not all about
affirmations and stuff but the thing is
when you tell yourself 94.8 when you
tell yourself ah
i wouldn't find this i wouldn't find
that then you're never going to start
finding these moves at some point
there has to come a time when you are
the fir when you first time that you
play this kind of move
right there there has to be a first time
that you play a move like bishop f5
and if you always tell yourself ah i
don't have the capacity to play such a
move
then you never will you at some point
you have to
you have to be your own biggest
cheerleader uh because
nobody else will uh at some point
okay sorry to preach but that's my
opinion
okay uh kazvar off because well because
because there's no other good square for
the bishop like this is not great to
fianchetto
but fianchettoing in general is pretty
solid so you can think of this in terms
of potential energy
right not every piece needs to be that
amazing
this is and um the reality is
if you go e6 then you block the bishop
which i really don't like doing
so there's just this is like the lesser
evil right and if you develop the bishop
then you allow queen b3
well if he doesn't take your bishop
right if he goes bishop b2 i think this
is the main move actually then you know
black has several moves i can go 94
centralizing my knight
i can basically start preparing e5
exactly swirls and i i like that
uh comparison a lot
yes it is but as i am explaining right
first of all the bishop has potential
energy if this diagonal ever opens the
bishop is going to be a beast
and that needs to be factored in and
also like the bishop is just a solid
piece right it's defending certain
squares
uh you you shouldn't have this
one-dimensional view of pieces oh it's
blocked by a pawn therefore it's
terrible forever
uh sometimes it's a necessary evil to
develop a piece to a certain square like
that
sometimes the piece fulfills other
auxiliary functions that are harder to
define but no less important if that
makes sense
okay obviously as i've climbed in rating
i've sort of really um
i've emphasized these these other
factors
because that's what it takes to succeed
at this level
um but uh you know if you're like 800
900 then you should try to pull out some
of the essentials and not bog yourself
down too much of the specifics
let's say of this variation if that
makes sense
yeah so queen c1 bishop h6 is possible
but you could go rookie 8 and bishop h8
that's a typical way of defending
against bishop h6
well probably i should go to sleep but i
could also stream all night and all
morning and all day